hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Game of Thrones Q&A good
news too because the winners of the
books haven't contacted me I'm kicking
them back in in my episode 5 giveaway is
gonna be for the the to sign copies of
feast for crows and dance with dragons
amongst like the the many big questions
that you guys had like R + L equals J
there were a lot of Barristan Selmy
questions they kind of spoiled it in the
promo for the next episode just in case
you guys don't want to know anything
about that I'm not gonna mention it in
here just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen last night's episode so
here we go first question Carolin asks
if sir Barristan or grey worm died how
do you think this will affect Daenerys
his plot so just answering like the most
non spoilery way possible I'll say
Tyrion and Jorah are heading back to
Marines so the plot has to accommodate
that the show's been teasing us with it
and I think that Tyrion is very
important to a Song of Ice and Fire and
to Daenerys so think about the roles
that Barristan and grey worm served in
Daenerys version of the small Council in
her little trust circle of advisers and
in how Tyrion might fit into that Tyrion
not so great with swords but he's great
at dealing with big city problems people
problems or what Daenerys has right now
so she needs Tyrians help whether she
knows it or not I will say that what the
show is doing right now is vastly
different from the books Barristan is
supposed to have point-of-view chapters
in winds of winter we're gonna have to
wait like another year for George our
Martin to finish that book so we won't
be able to compare till then next
question 5 min asks I can't understand
why Roose Bolton would want to rebel
against the Lannisters right now I
assume you're talking about King's
Landing in the crown
well he has the bigger army and he feels
like he has the right to rule he seems
like a very devout person Mel Sandra's
kind of brainwashed him a little bit he
has drunk in the kool-aid she spent the
last couple of seasons telling him that
he is destined to rule regardless of
whether or not you agree with her
remember the scene when Stannis went to
get money from the iron bank so that he
could hire his army he told them he'd be
a much better ruler than Tommen would
ever be and I think that's true at least
in the short term we really don't know
what kind of man tom is gonna grow up to
be if he lives to manhood next question
Stefan asks my questions about Jaime and
bronze conversation in the
ship do you think he meant what he said
about Tyrion and was it in the books
well Jaime and Bronn did not go to Doran
in the book so that definitely wasn't in
the books and I think he felt like he
meant what he said about Tyrion he
seemed genuine
the problem with Jaime thus far has been
that he lacks conviction he's always
been really amazing with the blade but
now in this season this is like him
trying to take control of his life old
Jaime like season 1 Jaime would have
just been a bystander in all this he
would have just stayed at King's Landing
with Cersei I think he still loves
Tyrion but he did not release Tyrion
with the intention of letting him go to
kill their father so he is pissed about
that because now there's this big mess
in King's Landing and their father's not
there to fix it whenever they had that
scene over his body and Baelor except
that was what Jaime was talking about
they're gonna try and tear down
everything he did everything he built
for us that's kind of a meta term you
know everything he did for them
politically economically so Jaime is
pissed now that his life is in complete
chaos although it was probably headed in
that direction anyway so I think his
answer is largely a reaction to that
situation not that he really wants
Tyrion dead
next question Trey asks do you think
that Jon Snow will be legitimized in the
show and if so how much longer do you
think it'll take well he's gonna stay
true to his vows to his last breath so I
don't think he'd ever accept an offer
like that to be legitimized what I'd
like to see if Jon Snow is gonna be
endgame if he's gonna be like season 7
season 8 you know Battle of Fire and Ice
endgame but I'd like to see is them
reach a truce and him attain royalty
that way like in the shattered ruins of
Westeros someone has to take charge so
hopefully Daenerys will still be around
and Jon Snow will be around too and they
will be somehow part of the bargain that
everyone makes and Jon will be forced to
become a royal they made this big tease
about the Melisandre sex scene jon said
I don't care I love another it doesn't
matter so if they're making such a big
deal about him not wanting to betray
Egrets memory then what would be better
than forcing him into a marriage just
like sands is being forced into a
marriage but I think something like that
if the show goes to that place will be
like season 7 territory right now this
season is like Jon being put through his
paces and learning what it means to be a
ruler in my head Canon I would love
nothing more than to see him become the
next king of winter though
next question John Norris asks how much
power do targaryen have over dragons if
you're a Targaryen will a dragon know it
or do you have to be around when it's
raised from a dragon pup technically no
because if you remember there were a lot
of Targaryens historically that rode
balerion the black dread that were born
after he was born Valyrian is a good
example of a dragon that lived for
hundreds of years so a lot of Targaryen
scam and went during his life usually
according to the books you have affinity
with dragons or you don't but I think
it's implied that if you were to hatch
and raise a dragon as Daenerys is you
would form an even stronger connection
but like if Jon Snow secretly turns out
to be part Targaryen he would have
dragon affinity we have no idea how long
it's gonna be before he's gonna be
anywhere near dragon though so we
probably gonna find out anytime soon
there's a certain amount of loyalty like
you saw from drogon but they have free
will there's a certain amount of nurture
certain amount of nature in them the
problem that Daenerys is having right
now is that rhaegal and Viserion
have been chained up and they are super
pissed they're still connected to her
but they're enraged at their situation
right now next question
Lilith asks does it make sense for Varys
to seek help from Turan Martell I think
that they would support Daenerys well I
think you know Prince Doran would
probably support Daenerys I don't know
about the other sand snakes what I'm
hoping we find out is that the show kind
of bends Canon just like a little bit
and the Martel's end up being secretly
part of the Targaryen restoration Varys
made it seem like it was actually a
pretty big movement like a big shadow
movement from powerful people behind the
scenes without introducing a lot of new
characters that we haven't seen yet the
show has to bring in other characters
that it already has as part of that plot
and how many super powerful super rich
people have we met on the show that
would want to get rid of the Lannisters
beyond the iron bank
the Martel's are just like really high
up on that list next question Lord Gaga
asks if Jon knew Sansa was at Winterfell
would he go and fight the Bolton's with
Stannis well if you haven't read the
books there's something called the pink
letter that directly addresses this it's
kind of spoilery so you know I won't
mention it but I will say yes there are
certain things that would make him break
his vows all the people from Stannis's
Camp have been trying to get Jon Snow to
join their cause and he's refused them
thus far so what I'm hoping is is that
something happens at the end of this
season
to change his mind we could
see a pink letter type twist or the show
could replace it with something similar
next question
Ricky asks why did Cersei militarize the
faith of the seven when she already has
a Lannister army in the gold cloaks who
this is actually a really good point to
talk about differences between the show
in the books so the reason that Cersei
reinstates the faith militant in the
books is really logical really important
on the show it doesn't make quite as
much sense in both cases the crown is
out of my in super debt to everyone
including the Church of the seven so
it's possible that shows Cersei feels
like the gold cloaks are overtaxed doing
other things they don't have the time to
do the things that she wants the
sparrows to do getting rid of people
that are inconvenient to her like the
Tyrells she's trying to neutralize
Margaery by sticking it to Loras in the
books the crown is about a million gold
coins in debt to the faith so she owes a
shitload of money to the church
reinstating the faith militant is one of
the conditions that the high Sparrow
gives her for forgiving the Crown's debt
so Cersei comes off with this giant win
she gets rid of like a million dollars
that they used to oh so that's a big
problem off their shoulders but what she
doesn't realize now is that the faith
militant just start going crazy all over
the city
Cersei creates her own worst nightmare
in the faith militant thinking that
she's really solving one of her big
problems next question Intel asks who do
you think is ruling or a left at
Dragonstone while Stannis is away well
he actually he left people behind to
take care of it while he's away the
books you know kind of go in a different
direction someone lays siege to
Dragonstone we haven't seen that in the
show so they might just be bypassing
that plot really what they're doing is
looking for more gold to pay back their
creditors Loras is part of that
expedition because lorises and King's
Landing
doing something completely different on
the show I don't think we're gonna see
any of that Dragonstone stuff next
question Aden asks do you think we'll
ever see other locations like Kasai or
UT I'm curious to know what those parts
of the world look like yeah I mean I
definitely think that we'll visit other
places really what you know what happens
is I think you know next season we'll
just push deeper into like the brand new
places this season like Dorne and
Braavos but what I'm really hoping the
show does is go to the ruins of Valyria
right now there's not a huge reason to
do that
not as much reason
is to say you know go up to the lands of
always winter that's another place that
we'll see more of but it's almost like
each new season they try to go somewhere
new but it has to be really important
for the plot so if the show isn't gonna
do any of the the synodal plotline we
might not go to Highgarden the same goes
for anywhere else but you know I do
think we'll see more old volantis next
season more lands of always winter more
Dorne and more around slavers Bay thank
you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do do you know I think everyone was a
little more excited about this episode
just because some really went down
it's really once the show starts to
approach like the middle of each season
that it really starts to go crazy so I
am expecting like a steady stream of WTF
moments from here on out to the end of
the season congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner - red claw 87 you
in an HBO now subscription just be sure
to DM me on the on the back end of my
channel for contact details if there's
anything specific you guys want me to do
for my next bonus video just be sure to
leave requests in the comments but I'll
probably do is another video about
hardhome or maybe another Braavos video
so while you guys wait for all that
stuff to post you can click here for my
episode 4 video and you can click here
for my Star Wars day bonus video we
learned a little bit about some of the
new cast members so thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five may
the fourth be with you
you